what would the Dom be like without CSS
well as you can see here with the sample
page that you've been using it's pretty
boring but luckily you can access and
modify CSS with jQuery pretty easily now
you should be careful because changing
CSS with JavaScript or jQuery means of
adding inline CSS see right here it says
that jQuery modifies the elements style
property this isn't a good way of
building a site but sometimes it's
needed in this lesson we'll use it but
in the real world you should always
think about whether you should solve
your problem with CSS or jQuery the CSS
method is similar to the dot adder
method that we just saw one method
signature will get the value of the CSS
property while another signature will
set the value of the CSS property using
dot CSS can you set the font size of all
the article items to 20 pixels